on this episode I talk about my favorite
sneakers how I hustled a decade ago and
vaynermedia's holiday party you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee sheddeth
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to episode 52 of the askgaryvee
show big day today here at vaynermedia
it is the holiday party I don't know who
decided to make this a Wednesday thank
you right I mean are you guys pumped for
the holiday party
Thursday's gonna be a [ __ ] let's get
into the show
harvest funders ass what does hustle
look like for you now versus five or
even ten years ago why has it changed
this is such a great question thanks
harvest for it and I'm gonna expand on
it I'm gonna go long for him on I was
even talking to the d-roc and stuff on
that this might have to turn into a
three to five-minute video movie because
I'm starting to have this weird
realization I'm talking to Mike Trainor
Mike about this during the workouts
which is like wait a minute
was I really hustling at 25 to 30 I
wasn't in the email culture yet nor was
the wine industry normal society
the store closed at 9:00 you know after
a while 7:30 felt like the appropriate
time to leave you know I had girlfriends
that I lived with Brandon my best friend
who runs Wine Library we lived above me
and like you know I can sit here and
think about you know 8:30 at night on a
Wednesday at 26 playing like monopoly on
GameCube and that is just not even
remotely close in the equation at this
point you know it's really fun to be a
businessman instead of an athlete
because your prime is so much further
down the path and you have so much more
time to get there I know look athletes a
lot of those people those kids are you
know passing and junior high in high
school and so maybe the timings a little
bit different but you know the truth is
my hustle today it's at an all-time high
especially since team seventh when I
incorporated working out which is driven
me to wake up so much earlier not that I
have more energy because I was high on
sugar I've come to realize but I you
know I can tell you this let's start
with this
every person right here in this circle
this inner circle of five and
and anybody out there that really knows
and some of you've watched and I've
thrown up my calendar here and there
nobody comes close to me and really
sniffs my level of hustle and how much
work I put in and don't take a step back
and saying really because it is
literally every second of every minute
of every day for a very long period of
time and you hear about it
Alyx heard about it he was a fan he knew
what I was spitting through this right
he worked at vaynermedia but until he
got a little closer it gets really
intense it gets intense when I'm working
the way I'm working and I'm texting 17
times on a Saturday while I'm in the air
and saying do this do this and this and
this I'm gonna do this and this this and
this and this and this and so my Hustle
is up Linden ass in the first 30 seconds
of someone meeting you
what do you reveal about yourself linen
is a great question and I'm gonna give
you a great I'm declaring a great answer
alert I can probably get somebody to
consume something from me within the
first 13 seconds let alone 30 seconds
because it's not what I'm gonna say it's
how I feel see words are great but
energy is a whole different game and I
win on that game right and so within the
first 30 seconds I'm gonna establish and
have always established for my entire
life from first grade first 30 seconds
into any business meeting to when I'm in
a big off site when everybody goes
around the room and says mom Stefan I
work at vaynermedia but then I do my I'm
Gary I'm a Jets fan like I within 30
seconds set the tone vibe wise if I
don't get to say something which is rare
for me not to say something within the
first 30 seconds I establish that I'm
different
yeah I'm different your boy LVS what is
your favorite pair of sneakers of all
time
that's a nice little segue from the last
question uh my favorite pair of sneakers
a hands down is the 1985 I think Patrick
Ewing adidas
I'm a huge Knicks fan let me tell you my
all-time hated pairs of shoes every
single Air Jordans of all time because I
hate Michael Jordan and I love Patrick
Ewing and the 85 adidas like ass I've
caught a few of your askgaryvee shows I
love the content what are your thoughts
on Google+ why do you continue to use it
Mike I think Google+ is a failure for
Google once again a big company that is
amazing maybe maybe actually my pick for
the best company in tech in the world
but just doing something outside of
their DNA they you know they try to copy
something it was a it was ill-fated in
my opinion I still use it because
there's an audience of mine there it
ties in nicely to the youtubes society
there's a small niche group of people
that I massively respect from Google+
that are early adopters of technology
early Twitter users and they create a
nice community and much like every
social network besides Twitter most
social networks are not so social their
content distribution portals
unfortunately and and I've got some
audience there and I will continue to
distribute my content considering that
it's so native to the YouTube platform
where so much of this goes I mean
obviously people listening on the
podcast know I was talking abunch of
people that are listening to the podcast
hate podcast peeps you know that how
sometimes they go and run and watch the
show as men attacked one of our
vaynermedia employees heard me say Asian
and something else and thought that I
called you Asia because they thought
that I was thinking in the end I said
Asia and then I punched him in the face
and said do you really think I wouldn't
know that anyway so they wouldn't watch
the video is my point my big point is
what I think about it is it's a loss but
it still has value and that's something
that I want everybody to pay attention
to
nothing is ever dead I talked about
email open rates being down but email is
probably at the top of my marketing
it's not about a hundred or zero it's
where is it at this moment and where
Google+ is this moment is it still
merits the minimal time it takes for me
to post a YouTube video on that platform
and occasionally engage with that
community something that myspace no
longer brings to me but did in 2009 and
10 with Wine Library TV get it simply
being mom ass are you a morning person I
am NOT a morning person I I sleep like a
brick like I've said I mean I literally
believe that somebody could break into
my home stabbed me in the leg with a
knife and still then continue to steal
everything out of my apartment
I am I just sleep hard and so when I
wake up it's just not great that being
said no question I'm waking up a hell of
a lot better because am i working out a
lot of times I've been talking about how
I haven't picked up energy but what I
have picked up is the ability to wake up
on this five and a half six hour kind of
window that I sleep which I know a lot
of you think I sleep three or four hours
heck I'd sleep seven or eight if I can
really like when and if I can by the way
and this is a whole nother long thing
that we got to get into eventually it's
not about how would you sleep it's what
it's what you do while you're awake so a
couple things for the question of that
obviously today is vaynermedia's holiday
party please tell me in the question
today a story it's not a question it's
storytime vaynernation
tell me your most interesting story from
a corporate or company holiday party I
need a little gossip in my life and
number two why are you not visiting me
at the Wine Library on Saturday you keep
asking questions I get it we'll keep
answering them
don't forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel
you